welcome to this video playing mr.
serious William Paschal Paschal I'm not
sure not a very frequent opponent I
played him twice in one both games okay
and going for them the same issue that
netted me a nice win in the anniversary
game the number 3000 game very early
night we ate maybe I can get an F 1 93
year actually okay probably not but this
looks like a pure transposition to to
the main line that if we had a number
3000 he's going for this which is also
bad i believe he takes bishop what
interesting just goes back never saw
that line hmm but interesting it's not
so uncommon that black is some just
giving up this pawn them in the names oh
hmm so Bishop e3 he's doing NYCHA for I
guess
you can also just take i mean i can take
its not or the big deal check night
before i even have c5 as an interesting
need all right he doesn't react to that
c5 what does he just down no don't quite
not quite sure i think i will play the
move also gain some space down so no
bishop here or not yeah i guess i will
take can also check now on b3 not quite
sure what it does thou my bishop is
still a pretty miserable piece how do i
go about that maybe this check i can see
form intending quincy three but should
be too this could be interesting and a
possible queen be 50 it goes into a
self-penned okay it's not quite it's not
quite clear how can i can use this 985
quincy three is not bad i will leave
quincy for the night hanks and night c4
still i have opportunities on the long
diagonal right damn ok
so we should be true or what no then
look be eight hmm
can also play night sorry Queen B 5 by
the way now deaf to check is nothing
it's also interesting it's very weird
typically weird samish position that
nobody can really understands I have my
doubts really that is that it is good
for me the structure looks kind of
terrible but yeah not easy to play
interesting move here is one of the few
possibilities that doesn't doesn't them
correct my poor instruction can stick it
and we should be too I guess Wow very
complicated or Bishop b3 is stopping the
pawn it's also not bad but it looks
correct to put it on the diagonal Brooke
b8 is Queen a five Bishop g5 stuff I
it's not bad for black really maybe I
should go but should be three and just
keep everything eight and i will be
eight is coming anyway that's really an
annoying move can I do something about
it I can I'm going here who create is
probably coming but here's the price may
quite a bit already no not this time we
should be three or we should be five I
can't go into the five
so it's just or the other one I don't
know I can let's pick up your for first
and then see about time learning the
details oh yeah this is a good way to
lose the game running into a stupid fork
I didn't think about this at all it's a
shame I mean black was really worse the
whole time I think I stumble into a
stupid frog check ok d7 hangs it should
be 5 as an idea check maybe I can still
play this thing a little bit ok I could
have taken a seven yeah it would have
been much better on a stupid game really
I will go to a 3 ultimate lame okay for
that it was a very stupid los cines just
running into running into the fork I
mean I think black was really hanging by
a thread here couldn't believe any of
that and so Queen a five and cheeks
Teague's one computer gives equal or a
very slight edge for white so probably I
was too optimistic them but they're not
better here I cannot believe it they get
you for them yeah the progress I don't
get you for because of that that's
stupid fork this is all based on me
getting the four point if I don't get it
then this is no good and also probably
the reason why this is nothing nothing
much for wide no no no no I need to
correct this while I was playing I think
I thought I was better here but the
thing is I never get the e4 pawn I
simply don't I mean I can do this but
here I'm not doing anything I mean those
pawns are not worth much and he's got he
will pick one of them up i'm currently
with power porn ahead but it's not going
to do me much good and if this is not
working and it doesn't then this is
nothing okay I can feel good Bishop
before with with some kind of draw of it
it's nothing nothing much I never saw
this idea in this particular position
just Knight f6
interesting that's interesting maybe
maybe it's I mean maybe it's easier than
to start with this or start like that
that could be could be interesting to
avoid this line I mean can it be really
that great either yeah my doubts them
now okay the pods are really weak I
don't really get them get enough
activity there it seems to be okay kind
of kind of okay for black some some
moves just struck me as odd like the
self pin and so on and sometimes you get
a perception like if they play many
moves that you don't expect or never
would play yourself then you should be
better but sometimes this is just not
the case even moves that look weird they
can still have some merit and here in
black is certainly kind of okay yeah I
always thought that I could activate
this Bishop somehow it was c4 and on the
long diagonal but doesn't really have
lead to much okay well thanks for
watching